hi everybody thank you all for coming
um it is really an an honor and it makes
me so happy that this has come back the
new wave we enjoyed several years of
just having a really good talk a really
just good great discussion and then you
know there were the Lost Years
and and and we managed to get through
them
um and now we're back and I couldn't be
happier because it really is an amazing
time to have such interesting and
fabulous people
um coming to talk you know we're at a
point I think in the industry where the
word diversity in Dei is losing its
power
um or at the very least it's becoming
perfunctory there are a lot of
Corporations doing programs that they
label but they aren't necessarily really
changing anything so it is really
special to bring out a group of actors
who are all very unique and diverse and
have different backgrounds and lives so
that we can talk about what's happening
and it's really exciting because this is
a group of actors whose talent I think
the world is really just getting to
realize so we get to hear from them now
and we get to see what they've learned
how they've learned it and maybe we can
all learn a little something from them
we're going to start off relatively easy
and chill
recently Taiko ITT gave a speech at the
Hollywood Reporter raising voices
luncheon
where he un at an Unwritten script
because as he said we're on strike I'm
not writing anything
proceeded to talk about
the difficulty in asking people of color
to come to a panel to explain how to fix
diversity in the industry to quote taika
he said you broke this you fix it
and I think in that moment he spoke for
so many people who are
trying to say if if you're already a
diverse person in this industry
you're already you're here the problem
isn't with you being here it's with the
people who are receiving you and and are
not receiving you so it was an
interesting thing to hear somebody
actually in a room full of people
actually say
if you're going to burn down my house
don't ask me how to fix it you build it
back up and I thought that was really
interesting so I'm my first question
softball will be forever for anybody who
wants to say
if you're a creative person today and a
person of color or a diverse person do
you have to be an activist too
is it a neces is it necessary and if it
is is it exhausting or is it a challenge
I think it comes with the territory I
think like being a brown woman on screen
is a radical act in and of itself
you know I think I think all of us being
here who are a part of different
marginalized communities I think it's a
radical act for us to be here and even
more so for us to be honored just for
our presence and I think that's what we
deserve
I think it is exhausting you know I've
been talking about trans issues now for
16 years publicly
um but at the same time I know that it
is needed you know I feel like the
pressure of of asking like what can be
done like that shouldn't be put on us
but just being able to express my
experience to help other people is
needed so I think it's kind of like
knowing how to
divide the what you really need or what
the question is like instead of saying
is it hard like should you have to do it
no you shouldn't have to do it I should
be able to to like live and share my
story share my art but you know if you
want to figure out what to do like there
are resources out there that you can
literally Google it and find out
I mean sometimes the answer is Google it
I mean that's a complete sentence uh
anybody else want to join in on the
karaoke
I mean I guess like you know by virtue
of being on a show that's about autism
I've become kind of like like the person
that's speaking about neurodiversity
disabilities autism in this space even
though I've been acting you know I've
been a sag actress for I mean my first
job was like 2004. so there is a sense
of like oh my god what happened like is
this a bad thing to like uh be out about
because that was also a fear right
there's like a lot of stigma to like be
so uh forward and outspoken about
something and then there's like another
sense of like well I mean why is there
like no no differences on TV like why do
like why do people that look like me
like don't understand if they're
autistic because there's just not enough
creative diversity you know the
characters being portrayed so I guess it
is what it is and I don't know well I I
mean I think ultimately nobody wants to
have to do it you shouldn't have to do
it but also if anybody is going to speak
the truth why not us
because you never know if somebody's
going to any like and not everybody's
gonna have the same truth so you can't
just talk to one
which I think is one of the things is
the one in the room is an issue that we
always have and what I really like about
everyone's show is that nobody is like
the one necessarily
um with maybe an exception not just the
one a person of color or whatever that
it is
a diaspora of ideas and people who are
all either within the same family or
within the same kind of unit and I love
that there is such a breadth of of
personality in everybody's show and it
just makes it a chance for people to see
something that is not monolithic because
obviously no group is monolithic so to
be able to see that is amazing and one
of the things that I really loved um
Annie because I loved your I love the
dynamic of your show and the family unit
which I thought was really amazing and
in particular that it was
a strong Latino family but not idealized
to the point where they're no longer
substantive you know there wasn't like
you dealt with issues you dealt with
um perspectives and abuse and things
like that but it that wasn't the thing
top
it it you authenticated with having the
people who are going to be the faces of
the stories also be the people creating
those stories and I I think that's how
we get
um more of a universal idea that can
touch everyone like that's the reason
why everything everywhere all at once
was such a success I mean it's such a
specific story and the more we get
specific the more everyone's like wait
identify with that like I know what it's
like to have a homophobic grandma and a
racist Thea and you know what I mean
like we all deal with that in our
specific communities and I think the
more we have brown writers trans writers
um Asian directors and producer like the
more we have more of that at the top the
easier it is for all of us to do our job
you know I think there's uh something
that happens when people are feel seen
in a in a show or in any setting and
that it comes when
it you know I was saying earlier to
Young it's not necessarily when you're
you don't write for Latino you don't
write Asian you don't write black if
you're looking at those big kind of
things you're missing what's real
because what's real about everybody's
culture is usually the stuff that you
don't see because they're in the house
and that's when you see somebody you see
a show where someone does something and
you go oh
that that there's a there's an Asian
writer there you know and I remember
seeing uh being in a panel watching a
panel where um a black showrunner was
talking about a TV show that he was
watching from the 80s and it was a black
family and it was a bunch of black kids
and parents and
they're in the kitchen and as they're
talking in walks the family dog who then
jumps onto the counter
[Music]
um
and every single like black person in
that audience went oh
and he goes and that's how I knew they
didn't have any black writers because
yeah that's not happening that's not
happening same thing on Flamin Hut
there's a scene in there where
um Judy is
right and the sound mixer was I think it
was a white guy and he was mixing it and
Eva she said she was in the room and she
heard a
and anybody if you've ever read if
you've ever put a tortana Comal you
don't hear that it's just
like you it's and she's like why is it
sizzling he's like because she's burning
the tortilla and he's like no no there's
no sound there and that it creates that
shorthand that you don't have to think
about it where you're like okay can you
get the tomatillo when you're asking
prop guy can you get that and it just
makes it so much more beautiful and
cohesive and nuanced because you might
not have recognized the lack of sound
but you will know it when you hear a
sound that doesn't belong and that's
what understanding culture means because
when you understand what they're doing
and how they're doing it and it's wrong
then it's like it sticks out it's that
thing that sticks in your ear and you go
there shouldn't be sound there what is
that what are they actually making that
is making that sound when you know it
doesn't and so and I think it's you know
I know we have a lot of writers and
directors and actors in the audience and
I think that this is one of the lessons
that we learn is that
you can't write for something that you
don't know
that the things that people know about
their family and their culture are not
going to be the things you expect it's
going to be the little things that
culturally you know and you go oh yeah
no we don't do that and you need to have
those people in the room writing so I
think it's amazing
Sue Ann I want to talk to you about your
uh about your character Violet ma'am
hello so you know one again we love the
fact that in this apartment there are
people who are all um on the spectrum of
autism but they are not the same
everybody has as people do personalities
and differences and it presents
different ways and I think it's so
important but how much did you all
work to differentiate and yet not it's
it's rare that you see more than one
person and that it and and that it's not
used to highlight something in the film
it's not used as the crutch of the film
it just so how much did you guys have to
talk about like yeah
um what the writers or right right I
mean we were so lucky I mean because
Jason lives with his son who is on the
Spectrum so everybody that was working
on the show was like everybody brought
in a different level of sensitivity
around autism their own experiences
whether they were on the Spectrum
themselves or they lived with loved ones
right and so it just changed the vibe of
the set you were like I feel so loved
and part of a family here and so in the
auditioning process you know uh they
really encouraged us all to just bring
whoever you naturally are and you get
the sense that like um I mean it like
obviously the characters are not
um uh ourselves but we were encouraged
to if we stem a certain way or if
there's certain peculiarities and how we
interacted so I can I mean I can only
speak for myself I can't speak for a
Rick and Albert um and everybody else
and there was and it was so cool because
there was people actors who are on the
spectrum that played neurotypical
um you know like Robbie clayder Jr he
played um a co-worker of uh Jax and he
auditioned I remember we were in the
rooms auditioning at the producer's
Callback and he was auditioning for Jack
so a lot of people got to play these
neurotypical roles and you wouldn't know
you know Lillian carrier from
everything's going to be all right
so that show I think it probably
employed the most amount of people on
the Spectrum in front of the camera
behind the camera all over the you know
it was like wow it was so so easy to be
on that set I mean I think that's
amazing because it really is introducing
people
to a group that they don't necessarily
get to see
in a natural setting like it's you know
it's usually the device and this isn't
necessarily the device living is the
device this is the existing is the
device this is simply the color that
they that they wear on them that's ever
present so it's really interesting and I
really have enjoyed watching the dynamic
of it all and just kind of discerning it
so if you haven't seen the whole thing
you really should it's really
interesting to see how people interact
even amongst themselves
so um and everybody finds everybody
annoying which is a universal theme
right
I was like oh yeah yeah even that's
annoying to everybody that's perfect
um so Lionel yes
so I'm just going to start everything
with what I love about you and your show
that's good just down the line all right
so you know I sit there and I watch the
bear and it is
an environment that just seems feral
like as they're like making food and
screaming and shouting their cooking and
everything and I find it so fascinating
and wonderful
that you are almost The Gentle Touch in
the middle of that storm and as the
baker you are the person who has nuance
and you see the potential of having
karmi there and you are like like
whereas usually it's like the big black
guy is like right in the midst you know
whipping it up and being loud you are
the calm storm of that how did you find
that character how did you like work
within that environment especially
um I think it's one part in the script
it kind of was like that was a character
that Chris wanted but also I was
fortunate to go in like stage which is
basically like work at a couple
restaurants and in there I like talked
to like it was like a bakery and I would
like talk to the Bakers and kind of that
environment was like a step outside it's
like where they go to retire from the
kitchen so it's the intensity and
urgency of being in the kitchen without
like the the chaos and the Mayhem of
like cursing each other out and like all
of that so like I think realizing that
it allowed me to say okay cool this
character is kind of living in his own
space within this world where it's like
this is how it felt in the bakeries and
I wanted to bring that over there to the
show where it's like every time you step
over here it feels like a like an exhale
rather than like adding to the chaos
I love it I I don't know why I
necessarily know why I felt like it was
so revolutionary that like the the big
black eye was like the calm Soft Touch
in it well I mean because you don't
really get to like it's you're usually
like security guard or something like
that yeah it's usually voice and
everything and you know and and I I just
love the fact that you are like the calm
the quiet storm in the middle of that
and that you're baking you're you know
that you're doing something that takes
nuance and touch and
like that's so that's so unusual have
you picked up any baking skills can we
all get a kid a little bit I mean I had
to just so I looked like I knew what I
was doing because I was terrified of
because I think the especially like the
kitchen world they're very they can be
particular and pretentious about like
their craft and I know that like just
from like Maddie Matheson was on the
show as a real chef and then we had
another culinary producer Courtney store
and they were like you were speaking
about the specificity earlier where it's
like they it's the same thing where they
like sniff it out it's like we would be
doing something and they would say no
you don't sound like that no one in the
kitchen stands like that or someone's
drinking out of a that a scene where
someone was drinking out of a water
bottle and there's like no use the deli
cups because that's what we all do and
that's what people come up to you and
like talk about they're like yeah no
this feels real this is what a kitchen's
like everyone in the kitchen knows a
little bit of Spanish and because that's
like every like most most of the like
the line workers and everyone in Spanish
it's like little things like that that
made it real that's where I learned my
Spanish
hahaha
it's like but you learn the important
things
you can get it done yeah yeah oh yeah I
forgot yeah that's what I was talking
about um yeah yeah no I like learned how
to bake because it you just had to I
didn't want to look stupid and not know
what I was doing with my hand so I was
like all right let me take this serious
and go and just practice and like burn
some donuts to learn how to make them
what I got out of that is you know how
to make donuts
I was like wait what
yeah we're gonna talk later okay
so Isis
your show is just such a joy to watch
um the family unit I mean it's the
family that everybody knows everybody
just kind of
all the personalities and all the kind
of craziness but all dealing in love and
what I specifically really enjoy about
it is that
even they they welcome in people who are
not a part of the family because Beyond
culture there is an acceptance of folk
who either are uh Cuban but speak
Spanish cool you can come in and be good
or can you come in and just be honest
and truthful and talk like and and give
your whole kind of sexual gender
background which was hysterical because
that was my grandmother would have done
that like tell us more about this and
you're like Grandma no but also that
almost religion trumped culture in that
family and that it's so easy and
interesting to find people's connection
to others so it's not oh it's not closed
it's open and there's more than one door
to get in and so I want to talk about
the tone of that and in your place in it
which is very matter of fact but very uh
I'm like you're the professional working
person in that
how did you kind of how do you go
between like a hospital scene and then
into the chaos of the family and keep
your place where you can shine
Gloria is here
[Music]
um so for me I I want to go back to
getting the role you know being a trans
person
um it's rare or not even rare I've never
seen the character description be the
heart of the family warm kind hard
working like all of these things that I
feel like I am
but you know
um for a trans person especially like a
black or a brown trans person
that is not ever the description right
so
to see that and to kind of know that the
character is grounded in the heart that
I feel like I already have that's not
ever anything I ever see I'm going into
the hospital scenes we were in a real
hospital I get a little cringe in
hospitals I'm the person at faint when I
see blood so uh that was really
interesting I remember we had one of the
Medics kind of show my scene partner
Todd how to kind of do the Stitch and
I'm like there watching helping so I
didn't have to do like a fake Stitch but
it was still like I'm like that's not
real blood right it's the I'm getting a
little hot
um so it was it was really interesting
to have scenes with the family
especially the grandparents I don't know
if you all have seen it but especially
in season two I have more time with the
grandparents we went we took a trip to
DC a few weeks ago and I got to see my
grandmother
and I'm like our imitate life you never
see a trans person with the family
usually especially be loved by their
family so to have these scenes with
family and like the grandparents and
talk about religion and religion be a
part of my life but also I have a career
and I'm so loved on for me that is my
life so
um as an actor though that's not ever
anything I usually get to see for
characters for people with my background
so it was kind of easy to kind of sink
into that character for me but also kind
of shocking how much family and love was
on set because
I didn't think that would be possible
for me as an actress personally I don't
know if I answered your question but you
know you absolutely did because I think
everybody assumes when you get those you
know call sheets with here are the
characters
when it's
trans almost so often equals tragic
and that's the show let's be let's all
watch this be tragic and this is just
not tragic this is strong and it's
centered and it loved on and that's just
part of it you know and I think that's
revolutionary for it yeah uh Gloria also
knew that it was important
um to have queer writers one of the
writers uh JT is non-binary and they
help make my character or like you know
write the character which goes back to
everything everyone said you know to
pick up some of the little nuances of
the the trans person was so important
and then even at one point in season two
I had a question or I thought that
something and a wording for one of the
scenes should be a little tweaked and
I'm like what do I what do I say and I
mention it to Gloria and I remember
Gloria said well I think this is a
conversation you and JT should have and
you guys can kind of work it out and
even you know being a the Creator and
and having that that thing about you
where it's no Pride or anything to just
say you know I think this is a
conversation for you all and kind of put
it on me to to kind of have that I guess
power to to do that it made me feel even
more like family and welcome and like
wow I know she care about me but this
little thing was hard to say because I'm
not that type of person that like to
speak up you know um and Gloria made me
feel so welcome and me and JT worked it
out and tweaked it it was just a small
tweak but I thought for my community
um it would be a little bit more
Universal to to word it a little bit
differently and for someone who has a
little bit of imposter syndrome
sometimes to have that moment to feel
like oh wow you know she want to hear my
perspective of it that made me feel
really really good and also I feel like
season two if you haven't watched it go
watch it I I feel like you know it made
for even better season but also one
where I could be even more I can really
sit into who the character was but that
was also because I was supported in the
way I was by my cast and the Creator
thanks glow yeah that's fantastic
yeah I do think it's key that you have
to empower your actors to be able to
speak up and if they feel like they're
an island it's so hard to do that it's
hard even if you don't feel like you're
an island but it's that much harder if
you do and so to have people so that you
that are open and that you're able to
talk to who have some shared experience
so you don't feel like you have to
educate people while you give your note
like okay I have a note but first let me
give you the background of the last 50
years and like bring you to this point
so we can have a discussion to not have
to do that is tremendous and it's such
an amazing show to allow people to do
that
um
how so we there are so many scripts now
that are being written and made and
there's so many kind of people are
expanding their Horizons of what people
want to see but there's something that
I'm very curious about and it just
occurred to me because you're saying
that you so seldom see
um a character that is written and
specifically said trans and
is written so kind of beautifully and
nuanced but
for casting and this is a this is a
problem that I hear a lot from for
people for all people when you're
dealing with age and you're dealing with
race and you're dealing with gender
fluidity
when people want to find you
what's the proper way to find you
because in this in our world of how we
hire we're not allowed to ask
we can't ask age we can't ask Grace we
can't ask these things so how do you
want how or do people find you in the
proper way
it it can be anybody really but you know
Josie
I I guess I am I'm curious as to
specifically your question are you
regarding like as far as like casting
goes like yeah how how we want people to
find us human speaking a little bit more
on that yeah I mean so there's I
remember specifically that I was asked
this question and that's why it's always
stuck with me because I didn't know the
answer is that are there uh agencies
that are specific so that you don't have
to ask the question you just know you go
there that kind of thing is that the
proper way is finding
the the group that you know will give
you what you want without you having to
skirt that issue of asking people too
many questions that are not yours to ask
yeah I mean I'm with kmr and they are
the only agency that has a diversion uh
division which everybody knows because
of Gail and so if you're looking for
anybody with a disability I mean you
will come to now Katie McGrath and
they'll know exactly you know I think
there was a script recently that called
for a neurodiverse character and and
boom you know you're in the pocket in
the agency like they have a whole
spectrum of people but I also think like
it's not that hard like I mean what's
his name on euphoria that man was you
know on a corner of some street chilling
and now he's a movie star and like you
can bind people it's not that hard to
find diverse Talent like we're out here
and I think if people just put in more
effort then you know it seems like they
have been for the last several decades I
think like you can see people they're
beautifully talented trans actors and
people with disabilities and just people
in general that like haven't gotten
their shot and it's not that hard and I
feel like people don't really want to
put in that effort
I agree that a lot of people don't want
to present in the effort but I also
think people are afraid of how to go
about it and and taking a wrong step in
a lot of ways in filmmaking we we make
uh film and television and a series
amount of fear of making a mistake and
so sometimes I think it's just easier
it's easier to smooth it out and say
look just go to this agency tell them
what you want there are agencies tell
them what you're looking for and then
you guys have an understanding without
having to worry about it and so it is
it's a it's something that I get people
asking me and I go oh it's a good
question but I didn't know the name
which I do now thank you so yeah I think
it's an interesting thing because you
know you do have to be careful you do
have to give people the space and we do
have federal law that we have to deal
with but you want to be inclusive you
want to be able to bring people in and
protect the production uh and just not
step in it so the openness of people to
tell you the truth and to tell you how
to do it is just a huge thing to have
for people so thank you for that
um
along kind of along this line if you
don't mind Jesse you have
and so many credits which I think I was
looking I was like well this kid started
it like
one I mean like so was it then
how did you go about expressing to
Industry
when you decided when you transitioned
how did you go about and what made what
could have made it easier
from other people to you like how what
would have made it easier to make that I
think I think experience like I mean I
just gone into this industry like a lot
of kids do by it being just something
that's a fun thing to do and an activity
that like obviously comes with like a
lot of privilege to be able to have
family that are willing to support that
activity and you know move me to La when
I booked my first show when I was like
10 years old
and then it became like a job which I
didn't really realize but I I kept
booking like these roles
um and then it just like wouldn't stop
and then I sort of found myself like
quartering this Market of like a gay boy
which is like every single you know role
with a gay boy in it my name was in the
script where it was like think me you
know what I mean and so I feel like I
was told who I was before I could
realize who I was which I think is a
very damaging thing that our industry
does to you no matter what identity you
come from and I think you know I've
known who I was since I was
four years old in my heart but I think
as far as realizing that
it took several years and I think it
only made it harder that I was in an
industry that was like shoving me into a
corner and everywhere I looked I was
like
I want to go out on the street and be
myself and have these experiences but I
have you know representatives and my
parents telling me like hey you can't
wear that can't be seen with that
because contractually you're obligated
to show up as this person and you know
I'm going to high school and there's
Billboards of me on Senza Boulevard like
which I mean period like everyone's on
the boulevard but I'm also like you know
how am I expected to
to live my truth with that incongruence
and that cognitive dissonance that
existed for several years and I think
when my show on NBC got canceled
that I had done in high school I was
obviously devastated because it was like
my first lead role on like a broadcast
network but I was also sort of relieved
because I describe it as like the water
sort of boiling over and that was the
opportunity for me to finally step into
my truth and that's when I did that
that's tremendous I mean it it's an
interesting thing to see how I mean this
this industry does pigeonhole you and
they just keep piling on no matter what
you do whatever what you say and that's
true of every
kind of actor I mean it's that's just
true of everybody so uh the fact that
you had a great family to help you do
that but also just that you had the
wherewithal to say you know what
I'm just gonna do which is amazing and I
know because you and I have something in
common
no okay
sorry not that one
I'm like welcome yeah
this is like you're coming out imagine I
know
right here at this panel
um no far less cool Sacramento Davis
oh that is where I'm from and where my
uh film that I was in
um indeed Spirit award nominated
um other people took place because Chris
Kelly the creators from Sacramento
Sacramento and that's where I'm from too
born and raised I know where did you go
to high school
Del Campo
Northern so now how does it feel though
I know sorry we're just having a reunion
um but how does it feel now to know that
in places like Sacramento where you know
there's not a lot of anything at all
um that people now can look at you and
say oh wait now I can find my truth
because I can see it more maybe somebody
else gets to LeapFrog some of the
process that you had to go through
they either choose to be on earth or
they feel validated on Earth because of
you and that is like the only reason to
to be so
on the Forefront of all of this and to
be so vocal is is for that I was just in
Davis this past weekend and I saw some
of these neighbors of mine I'm like
y'all they're Queer as but like no
one I had no idea at the time and I was
the only one I felt so other and I felt
so different I'm like but you're one of
us
and now and they were like thanking me
and I had no idea why they were thanking
me for being so myself because I was
just existing
um but yeah I think like it's a funny
thing we all probably relate to that
going back to your hometown and just
like seeing how people evolve but
Sacramento is still not great
no it's a fine place
it's a fine place to live if you want to
be bored
It's A Fine Place to be born
um and then I got luggage and left
um so
Young
so you started off as a musician
violin for a while
so I'm curious because when you decide
to kind of explore acting and now that
you've done it for a while what does
acting do for you that is different from
music as a creative Outlet
I think for music it's developed into
something that's more uh private for me
it's something I I do to individually
express any feeling or emotion or energy
but for acting it's something more to be
shared and it's a very collaborative
experience especially in film and the
longer I'm in this I'm realizing this
the whole nature of this job outside of
production outside of set it is more and
more people-centered people focused and
as a
as a self-proclaiming introvert I my
music is very personal and and something
I do at home or alone but
um
I think part of me needs to have a human
experience with other people something
like this even and and to be on a panel
with such talented artists I think
that's also something I secretly yearn
for that I I didn't realize until I got
into this industry
although let's not forget it can be
exhausting and there's a lot of cons
that come with the pros but I think I'm
blessed to be here and uh acting has
always been this EX
if it's like a spirit or energy entity I
think she's this divine feminine spirit
that seems to
um just carry me through all kinds of
situations throughout my life whether or
not I was aware she was watching over me
or not
like man we're on the right panel
it's like a sensory yeah like it's this
shit's in 4D and like I felt that
well done my man I love that it was she
by the way yeah I like everybody in the
panel went oh
we can always
yeah
it is such an interesting thing that
it filled a part of you that it may you
may not have been aware that you were
looking for at the beginning but when
you but when you taste it
it becomes a craving you know it became
something that you have to
seek out and enjoy and the more you the
more you enjoy it the more you want so I
think it's an interesting thing that I
find that actors so often have is that
they touched it and now they just are
seeking that again it's
in a very
um a filmmaker Warren Herzog speaks
about the Ecstasy of truth and that's
something I I I'm pursuing through
acting but I think especially as an
Asian-American boy uh early on I was I
was raised in an environment that's very
um like you're you are not as a as a man
you're not allowed to show emotion you
are not allowed to cry or or yell or
show any kind of extreme form you have
to be even Keel uh which I think has its
purpose in some situations but once I
got to drama school once I started
working on very very
um human experiences then that's when I
started to feel
more human and and I was allowed to in
in these um in in theaters with black
walls like this and we're all wearing
black and we're
um we don't have to be whoever we were
when we started I think that's very
liberating and that's what I mean by
this maternal thing this this this kind
of maternal energy that's that allows
you to exist rather than telling you
what what to exist as
Santa
[Applause]
I don't carry it I was like
I was like so lukita sorry
you're gonna follow him
um
you know what I love about uh you and
your wonderful show shrinking
it is yeah by all means
[Applause]
that too obviously like Jason Siegel is
kind of a lead character a lead actor in
that you know he he's the the guy
but if he is kind of the the Earth
you're the son in that show every
relationship revolves around their
relation to you
and I find that to be so interesting and
so heartening that you're able to stand
there
dealing with
the gravity of that I'm going to keep
that metaphor going
um and and able to hold up so well
because it is it's like the neighbors
are taking care of you your father was
lacking and taking care of you you're
the relationship with a new person like
all of that kind of comes to you and you
are the linchpin of that if it doesn't
work then nothing works
so I'm wondering how you were able at
just I mean
at a young age to be able to relate to
everybody who has to then relate to you
where do you find that
[Music]
I follow you and all
okay you need a goddess I
I
think acting is our job is to find truth
our job at the end of the day is to uh
find that little nugget that
is Magic and try and Infuse your
performance with that so
anybody can relate to it in a sense
um I was really fortunate to work with
this
insane Ensemble that have these
beautiful vibrant careers
um and I just felt like every day on set
was a lesson
um
and I learned so much
um I was really really nervous honestly
like working with them like it's Jason
Siegel and Harrison Ford and Jessica
Williams and like the ah
um but yeah I remember like the first
day on set I feel like I came on to set
with like a blind confidence I kind of
like dissociated from the fact that I
was doing the show and I like showed up
and I was like okay I'm a professional
like this is just every all day
um and then
Jason and Krista and Harrison Ford are
there and
I got so nervous
um before uh starting my first scene and
I had met Jason a couple times before so
I had a little bit more of a connection
with him and I felt a little bit more
comfortable with him
um and I remember everybody left the
room on the first day and it was just me
and Jason and I turned to him and I was
like dude I'm so
like this is this is so scary
um and he
like made me sit down
and he said Hey kid
you don't have anything to prove here
your only job is to work hard and focus
on the work and having that little
nugget of advice going into this
um crazy Ensemble was like my anchor
just like going into work every day
being like
I'm a professional I'm this is my work
this is my job this is something I truly
care about and then
that
um kind of lifted my veil of anxiety
going into the project and I think that
also lifted that veil of
like the pressure of feeling like I had
to relate to everybody or find that
magic nugget I just kind of let it all
go and
had really people a really fantastic
actors on the other side that were that
I had the privilege of bouncing off of
so it's very sweet to say that I was
like this through line for all of it but
I really couldn't have done it if every
single other person on that set every
single writer wasn't so specific and
Brilliant with what they wanted to do
and then
so willing to like throw that out all
out on the all out the window on the day
and just like play and have fun
no it absolutely made sense
no I mean I I think that's one of the
greatest lessons you can give to people
who are creating anything is that you go
in with a plan and then when you start
you can throw away the plan like when
you know what you need you don't have to
drill down the the minutia and so that
ability to do that allows your actors to
play and to grow and to give you things
that you never imagined and so I think
that was a beautiful idea of how people
should run sets do you think Jason was
really great because he started in such
so long and as a pretty young man
himself and oh sure I mean he definitely
saw I could sense that he felt a part of
himself in me like being young and
growing up on a set I mean he did Freaks
and Geeks when he was the age that I am
now doing drinking
um and
he was just like my biggest cheerleader
the whole time he was always looking out
for me and making sure that I was
comfortable and making sure that
um I
yeah I had a good environment yeah
that's fantastic he's the best
he's amazing
um okay so I have a question that's uh
maybe a little odd
so you know when we go to Sundance or
you go to festivals you eat all around
there are the houses right there's black
house latinx house indigenous house gold
house Muslim house there are a lot of
houses that are
undeniably safe spaces for people to
gather and have conversations and and
support each other and and in that I
think that that
um a really wonderful thing but I wonder
do you think we might also be siloing
ourselves a little like is there a place
where all the people from all the
different houses should be together
because everybody's got the same
challenges everybody's kind of working
on that same process so what do you
think is it do is it healthy is it not
healthy or is it somewhere in between
that everybody kind of has their this is
the gold house this is where the Asians
go when they want to go you know at
Sundance this is where the blacks go
they go to the black house how do we how
do we mix it up a little bit
do we just have a house I've never
personally been but I'm the type of
person I want to go to takes all the
houses
like I'm trying to go everywhere you
know I know I feel so good in so many
different spaces but sometimes I know it
is important especially to be a person
of color to to have you know when you
might go somewhere you might be the only
person you know sometimes it is
important to have like like-minded
people around you to also celebrate with
but I'm the type of person I'm trying to
dip in and do it through all the houses
and I'll meet everyone so that's just me
now so I can't speak for nobody else
what do I think do we think is is there
a way where everybody can collaborate is
there a way where we can all meet each
other
it's just a difficult question
apparently it is because we have no
houses like that so well this is so rare
I'm sorry I just did my genealogy and I
learned I've learned that we are what
else
but everybody on the planet is only as
far removed as there's as our 70th
cousin
we're all family guys we're all really
you go back to the 70th cousin you are
like like connected to every single
human on the planet alive today like I
know I was like who's like I had a I had
an indigenous like relative as someone
who was French I was like where is all
these people coming you know and they're
somewhere down the road I had a great
ancestor that veered off and we're
connected we're seventh eighth cousins
and you know so that's really cool right
so
yeah it's cool it's it's an amazing
perspective like we are really just
Generations away from being in the same
house hanging out and being family and
so how do we how do we get back there
how do we get back to like being in each
other's houses
other than Isis who's just gonna walk in
the door as long as you're not in the in
the jailhouse just go and have fun
uh you know I feel like everyone should
just
go have fun you know I feel like you'll
naturally meet people from different
cultures or just in general people who
you Vibe with and sometimes that might
be in a different house than you think
you belong you know yeah okay here we
are as long as it's not the jailhouse
that's the most important
well I so I so then there you are when
everybody is at Sundance or whatever
Festival you all will be at look for the
houses go visit all of them they all
really are have have great programming
and things and
it's nice to be able to see it but I
wonder how we can in encourage it more
you know to get people to come out of
their
it's hard to get people to break out of
what they're used to and familiar and to
walk into someone else's house donuts
donuts
how to show up at every festival with
donuts is what you're saying
flavored Donuts
latinx house all right yeah yeah Sue
Ann's like making a list she's like
here's what we need red bean Donuts at
the gold house five billion dozen donuts
all out so so Ann I want to talk to you
about your about violet yeah yes because
in addition to being this really great
show where you have the you know these
three really interesting people we also
see something that we don't often get to
see which is a young woman who while on
the autism spectrum is a young woman
she's exploring her sexuality she wants
to be loved and received loved and she's
interested in just in sex like it's not
altruistic necessarily where we get a
lot of like oh this person just wants to
meet that one person kiss one person
they die happy kind of idea
um and I love that you are explaining
somebody who has a much more
visceral idea about it how do you find
her like what was the discussion about
how she's exploring that part of herself
it's pretty bold
I mean
um hello does not every teenage enjoy
want to have sex
It's gotta be a thing right and so like
for somebody on the autism this is where
I really did relate which is amazing
because there was so many things from my
own personal experiences childhood like
I've been left on a date someone does
I'm gonna go into the bathroom and never
come back and I'm like where's my ride
like it's like the most awful heinous
things like you would not believe and
part of that is because as a person on
the Spectrum there is a different like
layer of trust naivety around you know
or literalness I don't know all kinds of
weird stuff right like I don't like like
violet had to be protected a lot right
and um but also Violet was very
headstrong like there's a like she wants
to be normal she wants to have like
she's reading you know like cosmopol I
don't know what do kids read to this day
but everybody's talking about sex and
it's like all your girlfriends are
talking about sex like tips here what's
up tip what's up Arby's
laughs
you shouted out Arby's
we had so much fun uh yeah because
that's what I did I was like my friends
who were like more with it were like
uh-uh girl come here let me do your hair
let me do your makeup like and like all
of that stuff was
um so foreign and people on the Spectrum
want it when we want to be a part of the
world then you're gonna see like how
hard and difficult it is and it's
difficult for everyone I heard dating
right it's like sucky
it is it is in L.A yeah thank God yeah
yeah like
it's like oh
what like ghosted I was like what
happened and be like hello hello just so
you don't like me
oh
I love that I do think that that's the
Brilliance of your show though is that
that's just life like figuring that out
and trying to figure out dating is just
awful on every you know it's hard when
everybody starts no matter what but we
rarely get to see that kind of moment
where it's not just presented like like
there is that kind of thing where people
are presented to be altruistic they're
you know oh I'm going to represent you
know an autistic female so therefore I
have to be the epitome I have to be the
you know whatever and she's just a girl
she's interested she wants what she
wants and it may be
as difficult as it is for anyone but it
might just be differently difficult and
I thought that was such a truth truthful
thing to portray
that it doesn't have to be you know I
just want a prince charming like she's
she's got the same delusion that most
teenagers do have that they're going to
find somebody who's going to be their
everything in you know by swiping right
um and no not all teenagers are
interested in sex I have teenagers
I'm sure
yeah just lie to me please
so I'm interested in how
what do you want to see in the future
what do you want people to know and
we're just gonna I'm gonna start with
you honey because I'm gonna talk to you
in a bit when when we're talking about
you know there's a lot of talk always
about people and corporations wanting to
break into the Latino Market that's one
of those things that you hear people say
and then then they don't know how to do
it for some reason I don't understand
like
the idea of it and what I like about
your show is that you have people who
what I noticed that was so authentic was
not just like story Etc it was things
like makeup I was like oh
the makeup is very specific here oh look
there and I saw it in with love too like
everybody has like something that maybe
go oh look at how they're doing that so
I just I mean it's amazing when you see
something and you go oh somebody did the
makeup like really did the makeup so
what would you like to see happening
with the people who are out there
writing and creating well they're
they're WJ they're not writing right now
um but the people who are creating and
thinking of it what would you like to
see people looking at or what would you
like them to know is there anything that
any advice or an idea that you want
people to understand
that's lofty
what do I want people to understand
um I don't know I that's such an
interesting question only because
so I'm sixth generation right I'm
American through and through I'm also
Mexican and now I identify as Chicana
um I
feel like I've
I grew up in East L.A
singing Barbra Streisand and Bette
Midler
like I was a Jewish woman my whole life
until
until I went to East L.A college and
learned about Chicano studies like I
didn't grow up speaking Spanish
I went to school with all Asian kids
until I was about
eight thank you mom until I was eight
like I was speaking Mandarin before I
was speaking Spanish no lie so I think
what I want people to know is like I'm
not a monolith I'm an enigma and accept
me as so I'm so and I say this with the
most
groundedness I'm I'm so good at what I
do in so many different facets I sing I
dance I act and for so long so many
people would tell me I don't know where
to put you because you're a little
Mexican girl from East L.A
and like my talent can't be boxed into
that it's not an accent it's not the way
we do our makeup it even though that is
important like I would love to exist in
a rom-com that's not titled a latinx
project right
because I feel like the industry
standards like what do I want you to
know like stop measuring me up against
patriarchal white standards
is I guess
I mean not for nothing but that was a
hell of a lesson
you're like I don't know and then
dropped a tooth bomb
go ahead Isis
I would want to say that
y'all have different experiences we all
have different identities
um within the trans umbrella so you know
listen to all of our stories you know
they're not one in the same we
transition different we have different
perspectives
um and also a book me like
that's the main thing like a book me
um yeah that's what I would want them to
know like if you know someone
[Laughter]
and and also
I you know pose is not here anymore I
would love to see more trans Focus shows
um but also I don't want it to be
labeled LGBT show like I'm just living
my life so yes it's you can put it in
the category but also don't just put me
in LGBT category you know what I'm
saying like the bad
okay sorry you say you're making me I'm
trying to be okay wait
I'm trying to be serious here yeah so so
that's what I want to say you know and
also I want to see like
I I love my character's Soul because you
see them have like expressions and stuff
like I'm a really goofy person
like we're goofy our stories don't
always have to be so sad and dark like I
just want to be the one that like
trips up and fall into the guy's arm
because literally that's I'm really
clumsy I have bruises on me right now no
prove it like that's me and I just want
to see more of that because like I said
in so many panels
a lot of people don't see or meet
someone who's trans and you only see
what you know in the press and tabloids
or whatever it may be so if you don't
know someone who's trans your idea of
who we are might be
different you know so why not see a
character like Soul who is lovable and
have a career and have so much support
and love so when you do meet someone
who's trans you will remember a
character like soul and you will know
how to better interact with them instead
of thinking that we are some freak Show
or horrible person or like we're there
to be Shady or you know what's the thing
like when they like Allure I don't know
something you get what I'm trying to say
you know like like more positive
representation of trans people and also
both guys
they're gonna focus and find out you
know what I mean they're definitely
taking this on the road
the book has tour
Plano do you have any thoughts that you
want to present
I'll be back on what they just said is I
think on the other side of it being on
both sides of the camera it's just green
light more unfamiliar like weird
specific things that's what brings about
because when you hire those people to
make something they're going to hire
people outside of the six same people
because they're not like oh I I just
want Brad Pitt they're like no it'd be
cool to bring this specific person I'm
looking for something interesting so I
think that sums up everything I don't
need to don't know long tangent that's
all I got
fantastic though and it's statistically
true that if you have people diverse
people behind the camera every part of
that production becomes more diverse so
and and not even singularly but across
you know cultures Etc so it does it
makes a difference in front of and
behind
so
and do you have any ideas you want to
throw out there a song I mean
I'm directing and itself yeah it's like
so cool it's you know it's a story
written by a young autistic actress and
she's she's like not autistic enough for
the casting world because it's all like
based on Rayman so they're like the
casting directors would be like but can
you do that more like rain you know what
I mean
she's just right and so how and how
exciting because of being like I was on
as we see it like I'm you know I'm
pulling in Talent like tal Anderson who
played Gia a beautiful incredible
actress like she is an editor and she
like I was like trying to put some moons
because I love space I was like can
somebody help me put a moon in this
music video that I directed and
everybody was giving me these really
intense like it's gonna be like hundred
thousand dollars whatever you know I was
like I can't do that I'm doing like at
home on my computer and she was like all
you have to do is composite it and put
it in the background it was and that was
it so autistic like there's so much
untapped talent and people who
um you know like I'm lucky that our
producer Suzanne Ellis is president of
Beacon pictures but she has two kids and
you know one of them is on the Spectrum
so they have a shorthand where it's like
they understand like Easter Seals is
here what's up
somewhere so there's like an ease and a
shorthand of people in the industry who
do understand no there's a lot of talent
like put them in animation put them in
the videos like these kids can act I
mean Anthony Hopkins hello guys
he's on the Spectrum he's Asperger
it's fantastic
yeah it's amazing
I know
um
um I'm just gonna kind of piggy back off
of what Lionel was saying I feel like
I had my coming of age during shooting
this show called generation on HBO and
that show was focusing around a bunch of
queer youth gen Z kids in Anaheim it was
very specific and
um it was a beautiful arrangement of um
an ensemble and everybody had their own
um different thing going on anyways but
uh I completely took for granted how
diverse my crew was when I shot that I
didn't realize how
much more space you have when the
comfort is built in when you don't have
to you know
tell your wardrobe person that's um
helping you out any specific things they
just like know how to handle you
respectfully or
um an Asian makeup artist that like
knows how to work with my skin or work
with my hair and like
I've worked on projects since that I've
had great experiences on but
it it makes such a difference when your
crew is diverse you just feel so much
more comfortable and as an actor like
that's like
you need that to deliver a good
performance I think or I feel
fantastic it's a great lesson for people
who are out there creating
uh Young
I'd love to see just really good writing
and really good filmmaking and to a
point where
we're no longer minority groups aren't
responding to anything we're just
putting out the projects that we like
and and that should just be the norm we
don't need to
be a part of the club or be part of the
old pillars just that should make
our own
amazing I think we're making Headway I
think we're doing it with with what
we're doing
well done
you want to join us there Josie
oh yeah sorry guys
um yeah put us in like different genres
instead of incenter stories not only
around like what we are but who we are
as people and not just uh you know
hiring someone for the sake of hiring
someone but also recognizing the nuances
in people's identities and complexions
and the colorism is a you know major
thing in our industry and especially in
the trans Community like we're mainly
only seeing white people of lighter
complexion skin tones on screens like
myself still hire us because we can do
the job but like also uplift our black
sisters and our Brown sisters and
brothers and siblings as well um I think
that's yeah super important I'm like
let's just do some weird you know
like
us and Chris Tucker
[Laughter]
let's go to McDonald's you know what I
mean like what film is that
put us on a raft
smoking and and wait and on a raft
that's all of us in the same thing I
feel like this would be a hoot right
right like until trans people are like
the Chris Tuckers and then also Kate
Winslet like we haven't reached equality
you know
I love it I think this whole panel has
now been uh can identify as Lionel's
weird like just do weird which
is
you can't go wrong
um so
um I think you all can agree that these
are just amazing talented people they're
so smart so giving
and so I want to thank you all for
coming out and just giving us your
Insight and giving us your perspective
it's always enjoyable always
enlightening and you all are amazing and
your shows are all amazing so thank you
so much and thank you all